[Music]
julia
is in gaithersburg maryland hi julia how
are you
hi how are you thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
so i am an 18 year old i'm especially
i'm a first year college student
i have a 14 000 car loan um i only got
it because
i need it i needed it for school i got
it right before the pandemic hit
and for work as well um i'm able to pay
for it so
um the loan is um me and my mom
co-signed it so it's just
but i pay for it um but my question is i
just finished baby step number one which
is you know save up that one thousand
dollars
um i'm trying to get out of baby step
number two which is pay off all my debt
which as of right now is just my car
loan but my main question is
um my mom is in a lot of debt as well
how can i help her get out of her debt
but
not only help her get out of debt but
how can i help her listen to your steps
and um
so that we can become financially free
together um you know work together
well i love your heart i tell you i love
your heart i really do
and you know unfortunately what she's
done is she shared her taste of debt
with you
and you know i'm gonna tell you you know
one of the strongest things you could do
julia
would be to get intentional and look at
getting this car sold
and get it out of your life and then you
saving up and paying cash for a car
and talking to your mom about how you
know that that's not helping
and i think you living it is one of
going to be one of the best ways
um but you know i mean you can talk with
her and you can
plant try to plant the seed but you
can't you can't make her
and dave and i have found this out after
many many years
of until someone decides they're ready
they're not ready
yeah and so yeah you living it in front
of her
and you've got the powdered butt
syndrome once someone's powdered your
butt
they don't care about what your opinion
is about
about money sex stuff like that so mom
doesn't you know
she's not gonna listen to you that much
i mean you can just the only thing you
can always do with anybody
is not to wag your finger at them and
say you know you need to listen to this
podcast because you're stupid with money
because you're you you could do better
mom you could do
don't wag your finger that way instead
just talk about yourself
because your story's not debatable you
know i feel so much better now that i'm
on a plan i got a budget i feel so much
better now that i'm getting this car
paid off or getting rid of this car
i feel so much better uh now that and
man if i could ever help you
i mean you just if you let me share with
you what i'm doing that's fine and so
um you ever had a friend uh julia lost a
bunch of weight
yeah yes they have yeah they inspire you
don't they
right without without coming over to you
and saying you know you need to
you need to take better care of yourself
mm-hmm they they just they just take
better care of themselves right in front
of you yeah and then you go well how'd
you do that
that's right what'd you do you know i've
had a lot of those discussions i've lost
37 pounds since the pandemic and so
i needed to because i was just straight
up fat and so
uh but everybody's all my buddies are
like what you do
you know it's the same thing and i i
didn't go around and say you know you
need to be doing this and
didn't look at my buddy and go hey you
got one of those things hanging on the
front of you like i do so i didn't do
that i
didn't shame anybody else right i just
said you know that belly there is
you know i didn't i didn't talk about
his belly i didn't i didn't pick on him
you know but i just
you know my stuff my clothes just fit
again you know kind of stuff
well and you're right dave her doing it
herself and i'm going to tell you at 18
years old
that's impressive for her to have the
presence of mind to reach out to call in
is a big deal i wasn't thinking like
that at 18 years old and so
you know julia live the principles young
lady
live them and be intentional for
yourself and please please please
don't take on student loan debt you said
you got that car loan i want you to sell
that get that out of your life
go to school part-time if you have to
while you work but
avoid student loan debt don't add it to
your plate